[Musique]
j'ar par Le
C'est de la vapeur pour moi
reconnaissances Mon
cœur j'urai sous Mon manteau De
pluie
Des poèmes roues De
russian on s'est qué j'avais 10
ANS j'avais Des tresses et Des
R sur le sirop buvait DU
et S
pourtant tu me
reconnaîas j'aurai sous Mon manteau De
pluie Des bottes rouges De
russie je Sais Que
j'aime
Cher as-tu Labas quelques
Amour vois-tu La Mer De ton
[Taper]
balcon je tu encore du
[Musique]
viol Ce Sera Le temps du
l Que j'auris Ce
jour comme sur la
[Musique]
[Taper]
photographie Des bottes rouges De russie
j'arriverai par Le vapeur du moi
reconnaîra Mon cœur j'aurai sous Mon
deuie les portes rouges De
[Musique]
russe